so if i was going to build my own tool  squad  with 15 points first of all i'm starting  with the tasmanian devil himself  why because he's crazy intimidation  tactics i love it i'm all about it  and then i'm going to go with another  sneaky pick wiley coyote  he's the most durable tune of all of  them he gets beat up every day and keeps  coming back  i like this guy he's on my team then  two we're going with speed right we have  the road runner  i think i like the chemistry between the  roadrunner and wiley coyote  you know they're gonna you know go at it  in the locker room and then that's 13.  then i'm gonna go with tweety bird right  undersized nobody's taking them serious  but i've watched enough cartoons to know  that tweed bird is one that has the  worst temper  so we just gotta tap into that to win  the game and last but not least  speedy gonzalez my guy speedy we went  with speed  he's the speediest speed is literally in  his name my team is winning  boom that's all folks